Michael B Jordan gained 24 pounds of
pure muscle in under a year for us
normal people that can sound like
sorcery but the real magic is the
Hollywood Health Plan he was following
take a look at Jordan's Instagram
pictures before his training intensified
and you'll see that the actor has never
really been out of shape still it's a
far cry from the shredded frame he's had
in more recent movies everything changed
with his casting as Adonis Creed playing
the son of Rocky opponent Apollo Creed
required him to look the part of a boxer
in Peak condition even though Jordan
describes himself as a competitive
athlete there's a different level of
Fitness required for a boxer according
to trainer Corey calier it was hard
going at first saying when we first
started he could barely bench 20 pounds
his legs were flailing everywhere he had
nothing he used to hate all this he
might have hated the training but he
can't hate the result since he put on 24
pounds of muscle in just a year there's
no easy shortcut for putting on so much
muscle in such a short time but a
Hollywood trainer makes it a little more
man manageable enter calier a former
boxer whose experience was instrumental
in crafting Adonis Creed's physique
according to Jordan calier was the first
trainer that he clicked with after a
series of false starts with others
calier stayed with Jordan when he got
into a different type of Fitness for his
role as Eric killmonger for the original
black panther calier played both sides
of the movie's conflict though he also
worked to get Angela Bassett in fighting
shape Bassett played ramonda the
matriarch of wakanda according to calier
whether he's training someone in their
20s like Jordan or in their 50s like
Bassett the technique is the same
focusing on high-intensity interval
training is the best way to burn fat and
highlight certain muscle groups
to properly portray a boxer Jordan had
to train like a boxer that meant 45 to
60 minutes of cardio daily along with
tons of ab workouts as for building
muscle calier had Jordan focus on
supersets exercises where lifting or
curling dumbbells are mixed with
push-ups or another workout in addition
calier pushed Jordan with circuit
training building his endurance with
quick rounds of different cardio
exercises I mean that's cool but you
know maybe you could just I'll give him
some drills
yeah things I could do them all if that
all seems exhausting we haven't even
gotten to the main event a full three
hours of boxing training following every
workout day in talking about the workout
Kalia had this to say in an interview
for Men's Journal I wanted to make him
look even more ripped than Apollo and I
think we did that
according to Jordan his lifestyle
changed completely once he began to see
results from working out for roles about
the change he said when things started
getting a little easier when you start
lifting weight you never lifted before
then it's this is all right so I learned
to love it when I started seeing results
being in fighting shape from Creed
helped Jordan transition to the training
for black panther where he used a new
technique called muscle training the
technique adapted Jordan's workouts to
match what the character would do to
stay in shape which helped alleviate the
dreaded workout plateau
the first Creed established that Adonis
was fighting in the light heavyweight
division which in boxing has an upper
limit of 175 pounds for the 2018 sequel
Creed II however Jordan had to bulk up
in order to fight Victor Drago The
Fearsome son of Ivan Drago played by
Florian montiano for context I even
killed donis's father in the ring three
decades earlier
[Music]
the film gives Jordan an unconventional
training regimen after losing to Drago
in their first bout Adonis rebuilds
himself out in the desert alongside
Rocky and his trainer in real life
however Jordan and Kalia did things a
bit more by the book
for the 2021 Amazon film without remorse
based on the Tom Clancy novel Jordan had
to develop a more holistic workout plan
that even involved tactical training the
actor was cast as John Kelly an elite
Navy SEAL whose wife and family are
murdered in a home invasion as with
black panther military training was
essential to the character Jordan can't
just look good he has to be able to move
and fight with efficiency his training
regimen included a 12-week course and
weapons training similar to what
real-life soldiers would receive calier
was also concerned with some aspects of
Jordan's physique that don't get as much
attention when he's in the ring namely
his legs and cardio the two employed a
CrossFit style program utilizing
high-intensity interval training in
addition to the 10 hours a day Jordan
would spend in front of the camera and
in weapons training
playing larger-than-life characters can
be a double-edged sword once you've hit
those Heights it's hard to come back to
earth after five years straight of
playing nothing but comic book
characters Champion boxers and elite
soldiers it was jarring to see him play
a mere mortal once again in 2019 Jordan
starred in the death row drama just
Mercy the film cast him as celebrated
civil rights attorney Brian Stevenson
working to free an innocent man awaiting
execution in 1980s Alabama we can look
at ourselves closely
can change this world for the better
Jordan has a lean figure in his
portrayal of young Stevenson dressed in
sharp suits that are perhaps a little
too fitted and not boxy enough to really
be from the late 80s one person less
than thrilled at Jordan's toned down
silhouette however was the real-life
Stevenson he joked in 2020 when he told
Jordan the one area where we don't have
to be authentic is that you don't have
to lose that black panther Creed body
when you play me you can keep that
Creed 3 arrived in theaters nearly five
years after Creed 2 with its star in a
new phase of his life and now with new
challenges to face as well for Adonis
the challenge comes in the form of a
ghost from the past specifically he has
to fight a childhood friend who spent
decades in prison and now wants a shot
at the title from the now retired champ
for Jordan the film marks his
directorial debut taking the reins from
previous franchise leaders Ryan coogler
and Stephen cable Jr behind the scenes
the film proved to be a new challenge
for calier as well he had to plan a
workout regimen that could be done while
still allowing Jordan to fulfill his
duties as not just the film star but
also its director training began four
months out from the start of filming
with calier putting his star through the
regimen up to three hours a day six days
a week after filming began however
workouts became less regular due to the
demands of Jordan's schedule he and
Kelly a would do half-hour bursts of
strength training calisthenics or the
same kind of high-intensity interval
training they had developed for previous
films
calier told Insider that his goal for
Creed 3 was to get Jordan into the best
shape he had ever been for the series
for Jordan there were other concerns
Beyond just getting swole the body of
Adonis tells a story in the Creed films
just as Stallone transforms from an
unremarkable heavyweight in Rocky to a
superhumanly toned warrior in Rocky IV
at this point Adonis is Comfortably
retired living off the fat of his
accomplishments in the ring and a new
generation of Fighters he is promoting
in fact Jordan went so far as to
describe his Physique in a 2023 GQ
interview as similar to a typical Dad's
Body while those who Rock the dad bot in
real life might scoff at the movie star
using their phrase his statement
provides a good insight into how Jordan
views Adonis at this point in the
franchise it may also be telling about
how he views himself compared to his
co-star Jonathan Majors who also trained
with calier Adonis like Rocky before him
always has to be the underdog going into
each film's climactic bout sometimes a
dead bod is the perfect obstacle to have
to overcome
much of the coverage around Jordan's
transformation over the years has
focused on his workouts and the way
different roles require a different
Focus an important part of his fitness
plan that is often overlooked was his
diet for Jordan and calier on Creed 3
the focus was on lean proteins and Whole
Foods like rice and vegetables with
fruit and protein shakes as a snack
while a diet of turkey and rice might
seem extreme calier is also a firm
believer in cheat meals which would
actually help fill out his muscles in
their joint interview with GQ Majors
emphasized how important a steady diet
is to maintaining such impossible
physiques claiming to eat about 4 000
calories a day when preparing for the
roll he also emphasized an even more
overlooked aspect of Fitness a healthy
sleep schedule about sleep he said sleep
hygiene is like everything you've Jordan
got great Skin Man and if you don't
sleep your skin won't be like that your
muscles won't grow like that
there is something about playing a boxer
on screen that seems to convince an
actor they could do it in real life
maybe it's the months of training
required to look the part of a boxer
that makes them want to take the leap
from fiction to fact while Jordan has
never said he could be a real fighter or
even that he wants to one of his
compatriots has done it for him former
cruiserweight Tony bellew who played
opponent Pretty Ricky conlon belue who
famously floored Jordan by accident
while filming the climax of the first
movie was impressed with the actor's
athletic prowess and work ethic in a
March 2023 interview with Virgin Radio
he claimed Jordan could be a real thing
saying he would eat a couple of these
YouTubers no problem
[Music]